a primera vista amina parece ser una
niña como cualquier otra sin embargo es
una sobreviviente hace cuatro años con
su madre abandonó las costas de áfrica
en un bote neumático en aquel momento
amina tenía tan sólo 10 meses durante la
travesía del mediterráneo su madre murió
su cuerpo fue abandonado en el mar
muchas mujeres mueren durante la
travesía del mediterráneo debido a las
quemaduras su madre también falleció
debido a quemaduras provocadas por la
mezcla de agua de mar y del combustible
que sirve para el viaje que estarme
durante al atravesar
la embarcación fue socorrida en el mar
por la marina italiana la pequeña mina
fue confiada a los servicios sociales y
entregada en adopción
silvia y su esposo buscaban agrandar su
familia
queríamos adoptar en 2016 el tribunal de
menores de palermo nos contactó nos
contaron la historia de esta niña con
unos cuantos meses de vida que había
llegado a lampedusa tras haber
abandonado la línea como amina cerca de
70.000 menores extranjeros llegaron a
italia sin familia tras haber atravesado
el mediterráneo' entre 2014 y el 2018 en
el momento más álgido de la crisis
migratoria el estado italiano debe
acoger cada niño que llega solo a su
territorio alojarlo alimentarlo y
garantizarle acceso a la educación
[Música]
debido al coronavirus a diarra de 15
años estudia a distancia llegó de malí
hace dos años y medio a italia tuvo que
desatrasar se para ser admitida en un
liceo técnico en palermo perdón para
toda la lengua primero tuve que aprender
italiano estaba inscrita en el colegio
luego en el liceo apruebo gracias a las
personas que me apoyan aquí y que nunca
me han dejado sola siempre estoy
acompañado acompaña está acompañada por
un equipo de operadores sociales pero
también por un tutor designado por el
tribunal de palermo quien viene a verdad
hola cómo vas estás bien es como la lila
es la representante legal de a diarra
desde hace dos años una función que
ejerce como voluntaria su misión velar
por que los derechos de la tierra sean
respetados como pueblo que pare con el
tutor representa al menor en todas las
formalidades administrativas con la
escuela la prefectura todo de cuatro
pero para el crack pero va más allá
el tutor vela porque el menor viva y
crezca en un entorno sano para que no se
pierda y encuentre su camino para la
propia entrada gracias al y lass diarra
encontró una familia de acogida una
pareja de italianos que conociera dentro
de algunas semanas en el norte de la
península
primero pasará una semana donde esta
familia que quisiera acoger la veremos
si le gusta luego si lo desea podrá
quedarse ahí definitivamente
se transferirá en palermo un centenar de
tutores voluntarios están activos hacen
parte de un modelo integral de
acompañamiento a los menores extranjeros
sin familia para favorecer su
integración
con el tutor definimos un proyecto de
formación personalizado para cada joven
[Música]
basado en sus deseos sus capacidades el
contexto y las necesidades del mercado
laboral en el momento del mercado un
mercado laboral en el que musa logró
integrarse tras cinco meses de práctica
fue empleado en este restaurante
siciliano originario de costa de marfil
atravesó solo el mediterráneo cuando
tenía 15 años
aquí me dieron confianza me enseñaron
todo ahora sé cocinar espaguetis
antipasto pastas descubrí que quiero
ejercer este oficio en mi sueño pero
sólo dentro de algunas semanas musa
debería poder transformar su permiso de
estadía humanitario en una visa de
trabajo algo que le permitiría concebir
un futuro estable en italia para gatos
bello es un chico despierto dinámico
vemos que trabaja para aprender para
crecer para avanzar trabajo avanzar para
algún día poder ayudar a su madre y a
sus cuatro hermanos que se quedaron en
su país
en este centro de acogida para menores
solos financiado por la alcaldía de
palermo musa vive junto con otros
jóvenes de origen africano la
preocupación es del laboral la
preocupación ante todos están
preocupados por trabajar por tener
ingresos no por su comodidad personal
sino para poder ayudar a sus familias y
enviar a la familia actualmente a cerca
de 5.500 menores sólo de origen africano
están presentes en italia quienes
atienden un proyecto profesional podrán
permanecer en el circuito de acogida
previsto por el estado italiano hasta
los 21 años